sur le toit de notre voiture une galerie
et sur cette galerie des morceaux de
cartes vous garez votre voiture devant
un parcmètre jusqu'ici rien d'anormal
mais là là le carton va intervenir et
regardez de quelle manière vous rabattez
les panneaux de carton ces morceaux de
carton commencent à prendre tournure une
tournure familière regardez le dernier
panneau se rabat et vous avez non plus
une voiture mais une caisse en carton et
il est bien évident qu'il va devenir
parfaitement inutile de mettre une pièce
dans le parcmètre vers 10h la
contractuelle tasse mais elle passe
devant votre caisse en carton sans rien
remarquer la normale pourquoi
mettrait-elle une contravention à une
caisse en carton ce serait stupide